okay okay and we're back or back now if
you remember I don't remember what the
[ __ ] going on this game use the keg
yeah good f is the answer ok dad good
and if I remember we have a quest i'm
just drinking make sure i think okay we
have a quest to reinforce the truck that
we just stole and we have to [ __ ]
make it like a tank phenom Stan okay so
this guy I believe actually it's like
right [ __ ] there yeah okay but can I
take down there okay how do we think we
need the fast travel this is great news
this great news okay but let me get up a
real ship 104 mm-hmm there is something
I think this is the best one okay okay
let's do this and I don't even hear my
dog Russell on but he is Rosslyn all
right now I put some peanut butter in
that little bone and he is happy as a
penis exposed to sunlight okay so oh ok
I got it now a mentoring room this side
guys because that's the way you got to
go they don't come with me
okay let's do this kind of slow but it's
okay
[ __ ] alright first kill the day
cresskill a day [ __ ] and i am really
[ __ ] bad this is why i should never
get my CDL lights it's okay I hear
someone screaming and can't see them
she's ignore when I'm driving can't
really say [ __ ]
yeah you know there's a lot of basic
[ __ ] in the world and you could just
you could hear them if you just listen
closely that guy had basic bed she's
these two basic [ __ ] ok here's some
basic [ __ ] over here you want another
example not [ __ ] now girls a basic [ __ ]
right there ok this is just basic on
'basic unbasic I'm day sec yeah like
it's very tiring oh [ __ ] where are y ana
let's got carried away with all these
basics see that's what happens to be
hanging out basics you start getting
carried away with the basicness actually
getting the other car is enough ok ok
all right I'm driving I'm just a little
driver and don't mind man and uh [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] fast travel a queef a
strap-on flipper we can't [ __ ] fast
travel in a car ok I can Mei this is the
way to go ok we have to clear the
workshop which means I'm soon or I am
this [ __ ] round there
okay got a crush these two
okay Ken that noise okay get get get not
[ __ ] look at that there's a lot where to
go
my car leveled up this is good and
very good where I get okay now we're
back up and we just oh hello the call to
basic what they always call it Andrews
get this guy you see death no he's not
dead
right oh really that's it good now I'm
very good very good oh look at that
boday ah a little may need for my taste
what else be real like some stretch
marks come always you know like I'm
gonna come yeah [ __ ] yeah I'll try the
car in help what they are they sick in
the head I showed some compassion
tomorrow got maybe six hours left okay
well that's unfortunate sir yes sir
rolling oh I can add some armor or
whatever you want me to give it a try
yes yes yeah now you're talking making
sure those bastards don't interfere and
I'll pimp your ride [ __ ] that's gonna be
a long defense considering like the kind
of time consuming to turn a thing into a
[ __ ] tank you just checking his check
uh let me upgrade I guess on the first
time to scale skills I can't see [ __ ]
okay can't say [ __ ] up kicks of strands
move in retiree slots juices repair
costs that's what I need be [ __ ] i get
that I choose that do I need like two of
them to move on
okay there we go whoo that's where the
next one XP plus so this would act two
of these are actually double my XP
that's insane + 100 okay okay sounds
good um great okay okay I did [ __ ] your
[ __ ] fast
whoo what buddy the booty lot of booty
yeah I am gettin kind of [ __ ] up here
don't you think okay yeah
oh [ __ ] i can't go away for the next
waves get away from next wave is there
anything the [ __ ] drink here I'm
[ __ ] dead oh oh [ __ ] that was nice
I'm done it'll have to do another guy
came was like
pretty nice out Jesus oh [ __ ] that is
badass thank you sir one more fight yeah
that's like my dad come on door can't
stay here what Oh kiss me we in my right
mind I don't want her home phone says
thank you to the loft out you can't
protect her not like you can I will
lesbian her up use it to her I'll take
care no way hey is this what you made
then give me what I amazing what are you
saying that I'm not going anywhere yes
sir no honey listen to me you have to
honey there's nothing for you here now
are you gonna kiss look at me I love you
and this is how I want you to remember
me and it's watch she doesn't think
Annette don't let me kiss her cuz I'll
kiss her kiss her right in the mouth if
I need to with me that's porous I'll
have to kiss her right in the [ __ ]
now that's what I wasn't do know what is
she like permanently following me what
do I not use in storage oh excuse me
yeah I need it back thank you
okay algae oh sounds good are they Oh
mom always wanted to come back here this
is where my heart is too
huh very easy all set let's go I say we
check up very nice very nice let me just
quickly repair this is where le guts on
when I repair at us and I'm going to
repair this I hope good good okay you
get great is there anything like I can
[ __ ] like this insane oh I can create
this
oh [ __ ] ok
um
okay i guess like this what's the Ripper
100 200 200 walking a durability sucks
dick what's the story building six dead
weight what's the strat though you know
getting the shock Bob no good good next
time like this too
this one
oh I'm making like a lot of [ __ ] okay
Jesus I really have no idea how long any
of this [ __ ] is gonna [ __ ] last but
vote yet yeah oh my god oh my god my
dick is a trembling right now let's do
this let's do this hey is this okay what
do we get idea again well hello look at
those tittays that's your heart oh [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] thing in the middle
brook
hey hey this is going well this is going
well
I'm going to be like crazy overpowered
soon enough
okay okay where we got where we got who
I [ __ ] up his lover
Oh
KITT actually close the loved one up
Jesus they got to go this way
because i think the yellows might live
walk or oh yeah this is the way this is
the way right here was it a fast travel
point
then we just discover this real quick
we're short bunker 20 this is the arena
okay [ __ ] that
haha
who I just killed a [ __ ] a lot of
people Jesus
who
oh my heading back to my main camp it
was just like a whole new thing i can
tell i know this is only thing that been
here before though I think we once or
twice to sleep will way back when I turn
all the circuits and ship
Act two [ __ ] you you you you chapter
five mixed blessings yeah baby
hmm
what the [ __ ] is that
no now
Wow and this place is all [ __ ] up poor
people is you can take a [ __ ] light
anytime we want we have a car thanks to
the money [ __ ]
[ __ ] Michael wasted no no no no no no la
journée energy drinks for something i
can add
I'm not doing too well I have to admit
I'm not doing my best
come on [ __ ] hmm can I what is don't
have like a shock thing nailed shop okay
oh oh oh oh that was a really bad plan
what does ona half
okay i want to get scatter runs with me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] how [ __ ] up that was
really [ __ ] up I lost some money with
that transaction [ __ ] that was a loss
investment [ __ ] ok ok let's see if it
kills [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] there I'll
brighten up our thing
all right let's get this [ __ ] to come
back over here this [ __ ] is really on
my nerves is he still in the fire though
yeah yeah okay I don't have any med kits
I'm just losing like 17 bucks of time
okay thanks babe a silly hat is 25 bucks
oh you okay one sec this one get Jays s
the light box that you'd be coming yeah
the cans possessed by a demon locked
himself in the belfry
please help us silence these meds they
are calling to the devil's decide okay
okay or how do I get there
you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I got talked a
lot oh how do you know [ __ ] working
computer working I got good
Mac Nats God get anything here is it bad
like till you robbing a church okay okay
I'll take a little snack a pillow I
deserve it i think that take some fruit
I deserve it
well I have got to repair some shut-eye
have like no money I even repair this
yeah okay okay what is the main quest up
to talk to mother hella okay
you need supplies you yesterday sure
thing can you order them very okay um I
don't know if you guys are following
that but I just just lost some [ __ ]
thinks I'm a soldier enjoy my game and
[ __ ] her own did so now we gotta [ __ ]
it figure out Sean on task backtrack a
little back check little
the new role is a fight anyone that is
not and I repeat NOT a charger
hey [ __ ] is [ __ ] anything better
okay I get we're just rampaging through
this [ __ ] wanna know why because I am
tired a games crash out oh [ __ ] my
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] way [ __ ] okay okay okay
let's move forward shall we
that we're just flying through this
hmm
you [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'll take his [ __ ] out my face oh [ __ ]
hey not doing too well that one okay
okay you continue I let's continue on
what is that stuff
should I got to go through here don't I
all right i'm gonna riverside the other
side oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at me recess
condemn though let's say if it stayed
here oh it stayed here so let's see if i
can actually use it now i think i can
actually okay so look at this idea okay
look at this pimping [ __ ] right here who
is like master reading with the [ __ ]
vana phone in his like face okay okay
okay okay now's their way I could just
kind of just gently place it yet
okay maybe I can get a little higher if
I just gently [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know what this is but maybe I
can get on top of it wow wow okay that
was interesting I have to say that very
interesting Jesus yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it's like you know how [ __ ]
okay though
oh [ __ ] get get
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] get look
close this [ __ ]
anything I take [ __ ] deccan throw now
all my stuff is legit Jesus okay well
I'm going the safe route okay your
paypal like the people I forget and I'm
a black girl with a [ __ ] gun slinger
Thanks get in here [ __ ]
hey you like that you like that [ __ ] I
can't say if take this most i could
almost live up again yes
like that hurt
you
okay i'm doing well doing well [ __ ] his
hat broomstick no way
ooh I like this guy over there wait we
shouldn't towards me what the [ __ ] oh
great
oh great I got this nut job to deal with
it's a letter over here
she's yes
okay now [ __ ] stuck it's great
it's gotta be another ladder around here
okay i guess i'm just going to
completely wrong way sign
Oh
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] there's so many
[ __ ] here like it's crazy ok I need a
new game plan how about [ __ ] up this
dude
you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright let's check up these [ __ ]
ok
oh how can I get up there oh [ __ ] its
way over there
hmm
normally I'd just be like [ __ ] it but
Wow
you see that let's have some [ __ ]
hmm
thanks for the snack [ __ ]
Oh
well I have a lot of pistols now
okay good good
I can i grab that
now
she says yes yes who Johnny likes chachi
tithing Eric [ __ ] yeah chop the Dutch
this is close quarters combat so things
are a little different right here
oh babe i [ __ ] love babes
ok
there are a lot of guys still Oh camp
great staff voltage brother hmm 163
defective this is the one I want upgrade
buck
ok which John am I using
Oh what the [ __ ] with the [ __ ] that you
come from
Oh
look good I like that
thank you 59 for that
hmm yes
yeah chicken let's guy hear me yeah dick
gentlemen can you hear my bra bra bra
this [ __ ]
guys like a little or a little classic
you know there's that guy I think I
check white that's good
get get get oh [ __ ] that hurt get a sex
did you make up your mind you ain't that
I make ahead i'll be my best you tell
you where they are proxy what's the next
its history one drop by drop okay
Oh [ __ ] a
mr. gray yeah Jesus sucked up
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] am I getting away from
this guy gonna pop this [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
I'm getting lots of ammo is this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] and the [ __ ] is
that about I forgot my money
I don't he shot them great [ __ ] stop
working all right guess we're gonna end
there right there